with wind speeds topping 250 kilometers
per hour
hurricane Ian ripped across Florida's
Gulf Coast Wednesday afternoon
waves turned streets into rivers
Florida's governor warning the worst may
still be to come it is going to have
major major impacts in terms of wind in
terms of rain in terms of flooding so
this is going to be a nasty nasty day
two days tens of thousands of homes are
without power as utility workers from 27
States prepare to descend as soon as the
storm clears about two and a half
million people were ordered to evacuate
but some stayed behind risking
everything it's my home
it's the only thing I have
I mean and my mother you know I mean
if that goes then
what what do you do it's been decades
since a hurricane of this magnitude hit
Florida's western coast curiosity drew
some people out onto an exposed seabed
earlier Wednesday the water temporarily
sucked away by the storm's low pressure
it is so dangerous to be out there so
even if you see the water receding it's
not the time to go out there and and
look at it or collect shells or whatever
it is the National Hurricane Center is
warning of catastrophic storm surge
winds and flooding across Florida as
people sheltered in place President Joe
Biden said the federal government would
help with certain rescue and Recovery he
is also warning the oil and gas industry
not to raise gas prices
do not
let me repeat
do not use this an excuse to raise
gasoline prices or guys the American
people Ian's slow movement across
Florida means the state will likely be
pummeled for days to come
Heidi Joe Castro Al Jazeera